- Kyiv, la capitale,
est encore en guerre,
et ça se voit aux barrages
antichars et aux sacs de sable.
Mais elle achève sa première
semaine de tranquillité depuis
le début de la guerre.
Un soupçon de normalité
est dans l'air.
Cette tranquillité
fait en sorte que les trains
en provenance de l'ouest
qui arrivent à Kyiv ont
à bord beaucoup de gens q
ont décidé de revenir chez eux,
malgré les menaces russes
persistantes sur la capitale.
de personnes déplacées de
l'Ukraine, un million esàààà
revenu; le flux s'est inversé.
Ce sont surtout des femmes
C'est le cas de Kateryna et
ses filles, Sv e e e et Marina,
qui s'étaient réfugiées à Lviv.
Se sentiront-elles en sécurité
Elles ont un peu peur,
maissisisisir de rentrer
à la maison l'a emporté. C'est
la même chose pour Svitlana.
elle sera en sécurité, maislele.
banlieue nord-est de Kyiv
où ont eu lieu les combats
La décision de rentrer
chez soi à Kyiv, la capitale, se
comprend, car elle a été plutôt
épargnée des attaqlelelelelelel,
là où les forces russes ont été
stoppées, de mauvaises surprises
attendent ceux qui reviennent,
et lesdededededededededededededs
de le faire.
Irpin paie le prix de
la première grande victoire
russe. Les ruines témoignent
des combats acharnés
qui ont duré un mois.
Les Russes tentaient de
IXs@<@pddduX@Lahsaéh
des centaines de v
certaines exécutées, mais
ils ont subi de très lourdes
Svitlana et Kateryna
ont été évererererers l'ouest
dès le début des combats.
Elles viennent de revenir
l'hôtel de ville, désemparées.
ououououous ont conduits à leur
appartement, dans cette maison
qui semble relativement intact
le coup, mais l'intérieureseses.
Six personnes occupaient
l'appartement. À ellntntntntntn.
Toutes les fenêtres ont sauté,
des morceaux de mur sont
arrachés, il y a des débris
partout. Des sol s s s s s s s t
laissé des rations militaires.
Elles ne peuvent que
deviner ce qui s'est passé.
C'est l' c c c c c c c c c c c t
endommagé. Elles tiennent
à nous montrer le troununununun.
et aussi la tombe
d'un homme âgé mort pendant
les combats.
Maintenant, elles veulent
l'l'l'l'l'l'l'aide à
cet homme, le maire d'Irpin,
Il demande aux exiléspapapapapa,
le temps de trouver
et de restaurer les services,l'.
Car 50 % de la ville est
et qu'elle est devenue un champ
de bataille. Et lui, un héros,
qui est persuadé que l'Ukraine
"Parce que nous défendons
notre pays, nos maisons
nos familles, les Russes
Ici Jean-Michel Leprinc